welcome to this video this is Alva
Alonso playing me here yeah plate in
before right all right good score three
and a half out of four okay still going
to play my name's oh oh I cathode
prematurely ok check I mean not that it
is bad but it's not what I wanted to do
ok it's a bit tricky here I think I need
to do this avoid the Bishop g5 pin yeah
I need to improvise a little bit you I
have a vague idea about this line but
the only a vague idea if equals if I
were to add you probably be six Bishop a
six 96 95 okay at least he's not
blitzing everything out quickly that's
uh
yeah and all night h5 yeah i'm on the
i'm on the right track night h5 was
played just recently in the US
Championship I narrow did scheme with
black against West less so but I don't
know that move really I mean I thought
38 but very much but at least here I
know that I'm going to d6 at some point
nie Dage five is of course preparing f5
he's taking a long time here when he for
if you don't play if or hear what kind
of sense does words set up make him ya
know he's coming up with the move yeah
the night here very often can use the d6
square and German now that's interesting
him now he's able to maybe put something
on g5 yarn ig5 to ship g5 yes yeah this
is this is a kind of way to play that I
have to be circumspect here that is not
able to sacrifice quickly huh Knight a5
or not i think i can still play the
movie he cannot yet take on h7 him there
is no Queen age five yeah for the greek
gift he has to play um at least one more
move to allow the straight sacrifice if
he goes by quincy to now I will play at
five I guess you're blocking the long
diagonal were always taking a long time
here so maybe he's unfamiliar with the
opening it's possible that he just tries
this out and now is some kind of trying
to find his way along um yeah I'm here
interesting I also kind of like that
idea to play t5
PM fighting fighting here for the light
squares I am not sure about this idiom
f5 has also a move that's them maybe the
more conventional way to play it and
let's do that that blocks the d3 bishop
and turn in most cases white will take
and then Knight f6 comes back into the
game I must be cautious not to Prince
Knight f6 yeah I did this in a recent I
don't know i remember i did this in a
recent game maybe it was just a bullet
game but I was anticipating the capture
then why didn't take and all of a sudden
I played Knight f6 it was it was kind of
kind of embarrassing okay so what is he
doing here you just canceled well why
not I wonder if I what about c5 here my
night only eight and it's not a really
great piece okay get you play rook c8
for possible c5 oh how embarrassing is
that I totally did not expect that one
coming ah ah ah yeah I am now thats that
happens if she don't play any warm-up
game jeff says some that we have to give
it give away a whole piece yeah come on
oh what a disaster that really doesn't
happen often to me yeah yeah it's just a
relatively normal position i guess and
yeah i have to play it what do i have to
do a c5 i don't know i'm not quite sure
about the high
move in retrospect this was what I also
thought was interesting and maybe I
should have done that it looks looks
okay if he takes here I'm taking with
the night and I'm very happy and his
night is back in the game and I'm
probably winning something here already
and he has to probably take on d5 that
looks very normal and he I can't even
take with the Queen yeah that's that's
probably what I should have done they
have a good control over the light
squares now so let's say here and I
don't know c 5 i'd not quite sure how to
assess the position maybe this is about
equal he still has chances on the Kings
side a little bit and this night is
still a bit a bit awkward takes a bit of
time to get in the game yeah I know this
is probably about equal I think what
this is a very normal position probably
theoretically explored somehow and Jem
Jem f5
and maybe could have could have played
that this is what the computer is
suggesting it looks kind of strange but
it's difficult to not lose the exchange
now yeah f5 probably wasn't a great idea
it's a that's not a very uncommon moving
in those structures to block this Bishop
here the way to age seven but yeah guys
this is really really bad yeah I have to
go probably have to go see five him then
as probably defer I just wanted to
prepare this a little bit but I didn't
really I didn't calculate really I just
played the move I didn't think what he
can maybe play
now this position is better from Wyatt
this is really better for wide he has a
big center and I cannot really increase
the pressure on C for him I have to
probably tell I also don't want this to
happen because this would kill mine idea
if I go let's say rook c8 and yeah
besides any tech to exam we should be
five or whatnot but this this kind of
structure if we if you think about that
yeah you place the six and I don't know
what I do I really don't know who gave
70 what yeah the problem is that this
night is stuck I cannot go here I cannot
go here I cannot go here I can go to g7
then to age 5 and then all the way back
so I'm kind of stuck here with the night
and this is a common theme in the in the
same mesh which is which which is
supposed to so I have to I cannot allow
that structure this is simply very
awkward I have to take him probably then
like here and this is not what you want
to do and then f5s sticks out a little
bit I can't play that position yeah it's
not like lost but I'm not very yeah I'm
not very happy with that maybe I can
play that but I mean the most nights
won't be great now that wasn't a good
opening I'll let's say f5 is not a good
idea i should play d5 and finally end to
the game though okay that was a short KO
but still interesting i guess thanks for
watching